President Biden's border crisis hitting
a new low as the White House is
reportedly considering a plan to send a
surge of Haitian migrants to another
country or even Guantanamo Bay that's
right the new report from NBC News
claims that the Biden Administration is
asking DHS about using a third country
to hold and process Haitian migrants
along with potentially doubling capacity
at the migrant operations center in
gitmo we remember those images of the
Haitian migrants that were under the
bridge in Del Rio Florida Congressman
Greg stuby is a member of the House
Foreign Affairs committee and house
Judiciary Committee and he joins us now
Congressman good morning to you so it
looks like the vine Administration might
have a plan when it comes to these
Haitian migrants but it doesn't involve
securing the southern border
yeah I don't understand why this
Administration just can't follow current
law and secure our border and return
these individuals to their host
countries let them file their Asylum
claims if they want to file Asylum
claims let them go through the
immigration process that our country has
set up where oh by the way we take in
more immigrants than any other nation in
the world over a million each year why
don't we just follow current law instead
of trying to figure out all these ways
that we can allow the border to be
completely open to allow for illegal
immigration to come into our country and
then when these individuals Asylum
claims are denied 96 percent of them
then this Administration is refusing to
deport them back to their host countries
even though a court is ordering them to
do that it literally makes no sense I
mean it doesn't it makes absolutely no
sense meantime there is this this
Halloween the Democrats own policies are
haunting them before the midterms see
how we tied it all in half the voters
say the economy and inflation still
their top issues in the final week
before election day and the FED is
poised to make the pain even worse
Congressman does all this all but
guarantee a red tsunami next Tuesday
yeah I did see that a Twix bar is up 53
on that inflation for uh Halloween today
so avoid that one treat as you're going
through your uh your Supermarket but
this is the number one issue that's
facing Americans This is what is going
to drive the midterm outcomes it's not
abortion it is the economy and it is
inflation because it affects every
single American equally and they are
feeling the pain at the grocery store
they're feeling the pain at Walmart Home
Depot you name it wherever they're going
they're feeling the pain and for those
moderate to low income earners they're
having to decide whether to put food on
the plate or medicine or put gas in
their vehicle to be able to go to work
so that's what's going to drive the
midterm and I think you're going to see
a huge sweep for Republicans uh next
week a week in a day from today so we're
eight days out now what kind of sense
are you getting congresswoman when it
comes to the Senate and what might
happen there what we'll be talking about
on November 9th
yeah Rick Scott said yesterday that um
he believes that we'll take 52 seats uh
I I think I think he's being very
conservative in that estimate I wouldn't
be surprised if we get 53 or 54 hold the
ones that we have to hold in the Senate
I tell you I think this is going to be a
marker for the American people we've
seen far left policies on crime far-left
policies on the doj investigating
parents because they go to school bird
meetings and care about their their
children's education I think the
American people have had enough of it
you're going to see a huge outflowing
for Republicans this November I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis